so whereas in transfer learning you have
a sequential process we learn from toss
a and then transfer then to toss B in
multi toddler nning you start off
simultaneously trying to have one your
network do several things at the same
time and then each of these tasks calls
hopefully all of the other tasks let's
look at an example let's say you're
building an autonomous vehicle building
a self-driving car then your
self-driving car will need to detect
several different things such as
pedestrians detect other cars detect
stop signs and also detect traffic
lights and also other things so for
example in this example on the left
there is a stop sign in this summation
there is a car in this image but there
aren't any pedestrians or traffic lights
so if this image is an input for an
example X I then instead of having one
label Y I you would actually have four
labels in this example the no
pedestrians there is the car there is a
stop sign and there's no traffic lights
and if you try to check other things
then maybe Y I have even more dimensions
but so now let's take of these four so
my eye is a 4 by 1 vector and if you
look at the training set labels as a
whole then you know similar to before
we'll stack the training data labels
horizontally as follows y1 up to Y M
except that now Y is a 4 by 1 vector so
you should be z' is a tall column vector
and so Y this matrix capital Y is now a
4 by M matrix whereas previously when y
was a single real number this would have
been a 1 by n matrix so what you can do
is now train a new network to predict
these values of Y so you can have a
neural network equal x and output now a
4 dimensional value for y notice zero
for the output layer I've drawn four
nodes and so the first node when we try
to predict is there a pedestrian in this
picture the second output will predict
as there a car here
predictors there a stop sign and this
will predict maybe is there a traffic
light
so why hats here is four-dimensional so
to train this neural network
you now need to define the loss of the
neural network and so given a predictive
output Y hat I which is you know four by
one dimensional good loss average over
your entire training set would be one
over m sum from I equals 1 through m sum
from J equals 1 through 4 of the losses
of the individual predictions so it's
just summing over the four components of
pedestrian car stop sign traffic light
and this script L is the usual logistic
loss all right so just to write this out
this is negative Y J I log Y hat J I
minus 1 minus y log 1 minus y hat and
the main difference compared to the
earlier binary classification examples
is that you're now summing over J equals
1 through 4 and the main difference
between this and softmax regression is
that unlike softmax regression which
assigns a single label to a single
example this one image can have multiple
labels so you're not saying that each
image is either a picture of a
pedestrian or picture of a car features
also and pictures often quite traffic
light you're asking for each picture
because they're the pedestrian or car
stops on a traffic light and multiple
objects will appear in the same image in
fact in the example on the previous
slide we had both a car and a stop find
that image but no pedestrians and
traffic lights so you're not assigning a
single label to an image you're going
through the different classes in asking
you
putting each of the classes does that
class does that type of object appear in
the image so that's I'm saying that with
this setting one image can have multiple
labels if you train a neural network to
minimize this cost function you are
carrying out multi task learning because
what you're doing is building a single
neural network that is looking at
initial image and basically solving for
problems that's trying to tell you that
each image have each of these four
objects in it and one other thing you
could have done this just train four
separate neural networks instead of
train one network to do four things but
if some of the earlier features in your
network can be shared between these
different types of objects then you find
that training one neural network to do
four things results in better
performance then training for completely
separate neural network to do the four
tasks separately so that's the power of
multitask learning and one other detail
you know so far described as algorithm
as if every image has every single label
it turns out that multitasking also
works even if some of the images we
label on your some of the objects so the
first training example let's say someone
your neighbor had told you there's a
pedestrian
there's no car but they didn't bother to
label whether or not there's a stop sign
over a LAN this is traffic right and me
for the second example there is a
pedestrian there is a car but again the
laborer when they looked at that image
they just enable it with whether it has
a stop sign over the traffic light and
so on it may be some examples are fully
labeled and maybe some example they were
just labeling for the presence and
absence of cause so there's some you
know question marks and so on
so with data set like this you can still
train your learning algorithm to do four
tasks at the same time even when some
images have over your subset of the
labels and others are so a question mark
so don't cares and the way you train
your algorithm even when some of these
labels are question marks are really
unlabeled is that in this sum over j
from 1 to 4 you with some only over
values or j
with a zero or one label so whenever you
know there's a question mark you just
omit that term from summation but just
sum over only the values where there is
a label and so that allows you to use
data sets like this as well so when does
multitask learning make sense so when
there's multitask learning make sense I
think it makes sense
usually when three things are true one
is if you are training on set of tasks
that could benefit from having shared
low-level features so for the autonomous
driving example it makes sense that
recognizing traffic lights and cars and
pedestrians those should have similar
features that could also help you
recognize stop signs because these are
all features of roads second this is
less of a hard and fast rule so this
isn't always true but what I see for a
lot of successful multitask learning
settings is that the amount of data you
have the each size is quite similar so
if you recall from transfer learning you
learn from some toss a and transfer it
to some times B so if you have a million
examples for toss a then and 1000
examples so toss B then all the
knowledge you learn from that million
examples could really help augment the
much smaller data set you have a times B
well how about multi tailoring it
multitasking you usually have a lot more
tasks than just two so maybe you have
previously we had four tasks but let's
say you have a hundred tasks and you're
going to do multi table burning to try
to recognize a hundred different types
of objects at the same time so what you
will find is that you might have a
thousand examples Pro tasks and so if
you focus on the performance of just one
task let's focus in the performance on
the hundred stars you can call a 100 if
you had trained to do this final toss in
isolation you would have had just a
thousand examples to Train on this one
toss this one over a hundred times but
by trading on these 99 other tasks these
in aggregate have ninety nine thousand
training examples which could be a big
boost could give them all the knowledge
to augment this otherwise relatively
small one thousand example training set
that you have for the
so toss a 100 and symmetrically every
one of the other 99 tasks can provide
some data or provide some knowledge to
help every one of the other tosses in
this list of 100 toss so the second
bullet isn't a hard and fast rule but
what I tend to look at is if you focus
on any one task for that to get a big
boost for multi toss learning the other
task in aggregate need to have quite a
lot more data then for that one toss and
so one way to satisfy that is you can
while the toss like we have in this
example on the right and if the amount
of data you have a huge house is quite
similar but the key really is that if
you already have a thousand examples for
one toss then for all of the other tasks
you'd better have you know a lot more
than 1,000 examples if those other tasks
are meant to help you do better on this
final tools and finally multitask
learning tend to make more sense when
you can train and pick it up near a
network to do well on all the toss so
the alternative the multi toddler name
would be to train a separate neural
network with each toss so rather than
training one your net for pedestrian car
stop sign and traffic light detection
you could have trained one year a
network for pedestrian detection
wondering that were for college
detection one year network response and
detection and one year network for
traffic light detection so what a
researcher rich Khurana found many years
ago was that the only time that
multitasking hurts performance compared
to creating separate neural networks is
if your new network isn't big enough but
if you can train a big enough neural
network then multitask learning
certainly should not wash in very very
hurt performance but and hopefully it
will actually hope performance compared
to if you're training new networks to do
these different tools in isolation so
that's it so multitask learning in
practice multitask learning is use much
less often than transfer learning I see
a lot of applications of transfer
learning where you have a problem we
want to solve of a small amount of data
so you finally relate the problem we
have a model data to learn something and
transfer that to this new problem but
not eat our learning is just more rare
that you have a huge set of thoughts you
want to use you want to do well on using
trim than all of those thoughts at the
same time maybe the one example is
computer vision
detection I see more applications
multi-thousand learning where one neural
network traded to take whole bunch of
objects at the same time works better
than different neural networks trained
separately detecting objects but I would
say that on average transfer learning is
used much more today than multitask
learning but both are useful tools to
have in your arsenal
so to summarize multicolor nning enables
you to Train one neural network to do
many tasks and this can give you better
performance then eager to do the task in
isolation now one note of caution in
practice I see that transfer learning is
used much more often than multitask
learning so if you see a lot of tasks
where if you want to solve a machine
learning problem but you have a
relatively small data set then transfer
learning can really help where if you
find a related problem but you have a
much bigger data set you can train in
your network from there and transfer it
to the problem we have very little data
so transfer learning is used a lot today
there are some applications of transfer
of multi Tod learning as well but multi
table learning I think is use much less
often than transfer learning and maybe
the one exception is computer vision
object detection where I do see a lot of
applications of training the network to
detect lots of different objects and
that works better than training separate
neural networks to detect individual
objects but on average I think that even
though transfer learning and multi-touch
learning often you are presented in a
similar way in practice I've seen a lot
more applications of transfer and
learning than a multitasking I think
because often is just difficult to set
up what defines so many different tasks
that you would actually want to train a
single neural network for again with
some sort of computer vision object
detection example of being the most
notable exception so that's it for
multitasking or much not learning and
transfer learning are both important
tool to have in your tool bag and
finally I'd like to move on to discuss
end-to-end deep learning so let's go
onto the next video to discuss
end-to-end learning